según ha explicado el presidente Turco
este ataque ha sido un atentado
terrorista dicho el mismo y ha explicado
ese que se va a castigar a los autores
de este ataque que no han sido
capturados porque según se puede ver en
las cámaras de seguridad que han sido
filtradas a la prensa turca una persona
habría colocado una bolsa con explosivas
en un banco de la calle de este clan y
al después de que esa persona se
marchase del lugar esta bolsa habría
sido detonada ahí entre los heridos hay
imágenes terroríficas en las redes
sociales turcas entre los muertos y
heridos habría niños y menores de edad
Perdón han explicado en su rueda de
prensa esta misma tarde unas horas
después del atentado que se espera que
este ataque sea terrorista dicho que
huele a terrorismo aunque no ha podido
confirmarlo después de decir que los
autores de este ataque serán castigados
y ha dicho que una mujer según el
presidente Turco tendría habría tenido
un gran rol en este ataque se sabe muy
poquito más de lo que ha podido ocurrir
exactamente porque Turquía después de
este atentado ha decretado un bloqueo
informativo
al atentado ha prohibido los medios
trucos que hablen y publiquen
información sobre este ataque si no es
información oficial que llegue
directamente del gobierno de hecho
después de esta prohibición se ha
bloqueado y restringido el acceso a las
grandes redes sociales como es Twitter
Instagram y YouTube